I have Nick Gillespie with reason TV
today we're talking with David Stockman
a former congressman who is best
remembered as the budget director for
Ronald Reagan David thanks for talking
with us good to be here you're back in
the in the spotlight and getting roasted
again by your fellow Republicans because
you've been an outspoken advocate of
letting all of the Bush era tax rates
expire
what's your rationale behind that well
in pure philosophy lower tax rates would
be better the problem is we've had a
30-year referendum on spending every
aspect of the welfare state we've made a
tiny bit of progress in 81 that was
restored over the course of the next
couple decades then we finally had
Republican government in the Bush era
both in the Congress and in the White
House and nothing was cut everything was
ratified in fact they added to Medicare
through the drug benefit so now where's
the total federal outlays about 60
percent in 2010 dollars that's exactly
right so now we're at the point where we
have this large welfare state that seems
immovable politically and this expanding
warfare state that both parties seem to
want to fund and in that environment
you're kidding yourself if you think
cutting taxes today is really cutting
taxes we're simply deferring massive tax
increases into the future unfairly and
immorally putting huge debt burdens on
future generations and that is just
wrong there's a presumption there that
if we raised more federal revenue that
would go to pay what we're what we're
actually doing now as opposed to just
give the government more impetus to grow
even faster well that's always a risk
but I think the fact is there isn't much
pressure for structural expansion of the
budget right now does there need to be
though because I've been Medicare
spending set to continue to expand
particularly after 2020 I mean so there
doesn't need to be a politician saying
let's raise let's create whole new
entitlements because we've got
ones that are on autopilot to explode
right oh yes I mean the cost trajectory
of the entitlements and the program
structure that is there will rise over
time and part of the fiscal battle will
be to find ways to contain that so I
very strongly believe that in addition
to allowing the tax cuts to expire we
need to means-test
radically the retirement entitlements in
the past few years we've seen under Bush
and then continued under under President
Obama
things like tarp things like stimulus
spending I mean it started under Bush in
2008 was obviously kicked in to high
gear by Obama are we in a place now
where bailouts will become a constant
part of American life well that is a
pressure and that is a clear risk I
believe in some ways it was a profound
moment in political history in September
to O eight when Paulson panicked and of
course Bush was a deer in a headlight he
had no clue about what was going on and
stampeded the Republicans into enacting
tarp
I was tarp a bad idea I mean we have
President Bush we have President Obama
we have Tim Geithner we have a bunch of
Nobel prize-winning economists telling
us that we have Warren Buffett saying
tarp you know that's the only reason you
and I are still talking that's the only
reason why there's still lights on well
first of all that's Obon mythology I
don't think there was panic on Main
Street in America what was happening was
that the big pyramids of debt on Wall
Street were coming crashing down and had
we allowed nature to take its course
maybe the goldman sachs stock would have
gone down to ten dollars but that's
their problem and that's the problem of
speculators who own the stock not a
problem systemic problem for the economy
maybe a couple of banks would have been
closed by the FDIC and whether you
believe in Deposit Insurance or not
which I don't it was there and that was
the function of Deposit Insurance Oh
what what happened then why did that win
the political battle because Paulson
frankly is the most incompetent reckless
secretary of the
every we've had in modern history if
ever and he had no schooling in public
policy he had no schooling in the longer
term issues fiscal management or even
you know what sound money is all about
for crying out loud and as a result as
the crisis metastasized in September
October of 208 and he got all these
panic calls from his buddies on Wall
Street who were seeing their pyramids of
debt come crashing down and particularly
when the stock of goldman sachs sachs
started to plunge he panicked there was
no philosophy behind it there was never
an analysis done this whole idea that
there was systemic risk it's just a term
made up by people who were looking for
ways to meddle in the economy do you
think he ran with it should the feds
have the Fed or the feds or any portion
of the federal government should they
have bailed out Bear Stearns should they
have bailed out Lehman Brothers should
they bailed out goldman sachs should
they bailed at GM do do bailouts at any
point make sense no I think absolutely
not once the broad public sees that the
cronies of capitalism are bailed out by
their friends in Washington or the Fed
why should they believe that the system
we have is fair or is working in their
interest isn't this the oldest story of
American capitalism which is that there
is always at some point there is
somebody who's too big to fail or more
correctly to politically connected to
fail well I think the risk has always
been there but historically there was at
least in the Republican Party principled
beliefs that the marketplace had to be
allowed to operate and that both gains
and losses would occur and even though
there was pressure from time to time for
interventions and bailouts it was pretty
rare if at all during the Eisenhower
administration for instance even though
Ike was suspected of not being a good
consumer respected a bigger cop if you
look at the
Tomic policy of the Eisenhower era it
was pretty solid he actually believed in
balancing the budget and budget balanced
the budget three times during the Ford
era again President Ford was pretty much
a free enterprise believer and there
aren't too many examples that you could
come up with where there was outright
bailouts but I think the problem really
gathered gathered momentum in the late
70s after inflation got out of control
because we closed the gold window in
1971 then politicians began to find
reasons for expediency the Chrysler
bailout was a terrible thing even though
it kept the company alive it's the
company alive long enough so that it
could die again and take GM down with it
and cost the second Bay Road in the
Reagan era I thought we were free
enterprise and mostly we were but we
bailed out continental bank against the
strong belief of myself and many others
in the administration but it was kind of
forced through panic what things began
to what do you do with savings alone was
that systemic risk when the Savings and
Loan industry collapsed well first of
all the problem that blew up in the late
80s was encouraged by bad mistakes made
by the Reagan administration the early
eighties we deregulated the SNL's and
allowed them to speculate in all kinds
of real estate and land development and
so forth per se it's not a problem right
but it's problem if they have guaranteed
deposit insurance and if they have
federal entities to turn to to bail them
out if they make reckless mistakes well
all of them did and so we ended up with
insolvent institutions in mass in the
late 80s and I think they did more or
less a reasonable job of dealing with
that because all of them were closed and
liquidated and losses were absorbed by
the equity speculators
and the you know jr. bond speculators in
these failed SNL's the depositors were
protected because that's what the
deposit insurance system is but it was a
good lesson that we had danger built
into the heart of our banking system
because of Deposit Insurance which
allowed speculators to raise money
without people worrying about the risk
of investing and they had access to the
Fed window which says that if you really
go off the edge of the cliff and become
illiquid because you're investing long
and funding short which is foolish and
has always been frowned upon by sound
banking theory historically we should
have seen it coming
with in other words the S&L crisis was a
wake-up call that Deposit Insurance and
the Fed were about ready to fuel a far
greater banking system bubble and blow
up and sure enough 15 years later that's
exactly what we had and then when the
crisis came we went in and bailed out
the whole thing again and have just
created the condition for even more
traumatic excess in the future now but
we've solved all our problems right with
the dodd-frank financial regulation bill
you know which is being touted certainly
by the Obama administration and I guess
by Chris Dodd and Barney Frank as you
know the be-all and end-all does that
change anything does it address any of
the issues that you're that you're
talking about and does it make you sleep
easier at night knowing that we're now
regulated in a different way well really
not at all because it's just another
sort of crony capitalist shuffle if we
really have a problem in our banking
system of too big to fail which i
profoundly believe we do then the
institutions involved are too big to
exist and by that I mean exist we have
access to the Federal Deposit Insurance
guarantees and therefore the ability to
raise hundreds of billions or trillions
of deposits
and with access to the Fed window so
what happened at the end of 207 before
the crisis actually hit fully the top
four banks in this country had five
trillion of asset footings combined
after the whole crisis of too big to
fail and all of the bailouts and putting
the taxpayer in harm's way in a manner
never done before today the top four
banks have seven trillion of asset
footings so what we did and what the
FIDIC and the Federal Reserve did in
their wisdom was to actually just
steeping and enlarge the problem so I
believe in narrow banking I believe that
if you're going to have Deposit
Insurance it should be for banks that
can lend for only short periods of time
for commercial activities where the risk
of loss is minimal and if you want to be
in the speculation business if you want
to be in the over-the-counter
derivatives marketing business if you
want to make long-term loans and
speculative real estate and even
business enterprises fine
be my guest do it as a free enterprise
financial institution but don't look for
guaranteed deposits to raise your
funding and don't think you should act
have access to the Fed window in case
you make a discount window that is in
the event that you make large mistakes
that is the fundamental line of
demarcation that needs to be addressed
and the legislation passed by Congress
the so-called thin reg doesn't do any of
that it simply involves 2300 pages of an
abling Act which empowers the same
institutions who fostered this crisis
the Fed the FDIC the controller to
determine what those mean and it more or
less is a full-employment Act for
lobbyists lawyers accounting consultants
and so forth to find ways to
build loopholes which is easy enough to
do now in the New York Times over the
summer you laid one of the four
deformations of the fiscal apocalypse on
the heads of pointless speculation and
stocks bonds commodities and derivatives
are you arguing that essentially that
these this trade only existed because of
regulations or of a government system or
a political economy where people knew if
they were playing around with that kind
of stuff that they would get bailed out
well I think it goes beyond or further
back than that I think it goes to the
closing of the gold window in 1971 it
goes to the and that because the last
shred of anchoring the US dollar to a
gold standard yes and because that
system as it had its defects Bretton
Woods but at the heart of it was a fixed
exchange rate system and an obligation
on each company in country including the
United States to settle its accounts at
the end of every year and if you began
to run chronic payments deficits you
were going to under that system lose
your monetary reserves goal of the fewer
the United States or dollar reserve
assets if you were other participants in
the system and what that did was foster
continuous financial discipline because
any country losing large-scale reserves
would find its banking system
contracting the interest rates rising
its economy slowing down and the basis
for sustainable adjustment to occur now
when we got rid of all of that and went
to pure fiat money it began a process in
which financial volatility and
instability reached what had been
previously unimaginable levels and so if
you have exchange rates careening all
over the place if you have interest
rates soaring and then declining and
then bouncing to and fro the market will
invent
Hedges which is to say currency futures
and hedges of every kind interest rate
hedges of every imaginable kind in order
to meet the need of participants in the
system to have some certainty about the
value value of things so I think much of
this massive you know 700 trillion
derivatives market which is out there
was fostered by the breakdown of fixed
exchange rates in the anchor of the
monetary system to a asset gold in that
case that couldn't be manipulated for
short-term purposes by governments in
central bank's once these things were
invented because of the turbulence in
the market for legitimate hedging there
was nothing to stop all the casino
players from jumping in and simply
speculating you know this is probably a
good time to bring up some of your
Austrian friends Austrian economist you
know on the one hand you would have
somebody like Murray Rothbard who
believed in I guess free banking but
also a gold standard then you had
somebody like Friedrich Hayek who talked
about competing currencies and you know
with the breakdown of the gold standard
of the breakdown of Bretton Woods don't
we effectively have what Hayek would
consider and market in competing
currencies different countries or
something like the EU to the extent that
their money isn't sound investors will
devalue it and and don't move you know
the market will respond to that why is
that not working in a way that Bretton
Woods might have at some point to kind
of keep people from just running up or
printing out cheap money well I think
because mainly the system that he
imagined if I understand it correctly
was privately issued currencies what we
have is currency issued by the sovereign
the United States in unlimited
quantities in the context of a global
system where all the other central banks
are lined up in some kind of you know
caravan trying to mimic the policies of
the fed mostly defensively when we flood
the world with dollars that the Fed does
they have to buy them up and print their
own currency in order to prevent their
exchange rate from going up so when this
is a government-issued
currency I think you get the exact mess
that we have today ultimately what
really is is the the issue is the need
for periodic settlement of accounts
financial discipline and once we got rid
of that what happened was something
Milton Friedman said could never
happened he said don't worry about the
balance of payments crisis under Bretton
Woods essentially closed the gold window
led the dollar float and the world
currency market will take care of trade
imbalances he was totally wrong we've
had eight trillion dollars worth of
cumulative current account deficits with
the rest of the world since the late
1970s
year after year what what is the real
effect of that though because some
people would say well you know what that
means is that we're getting more for our
money
now the real effect of it is that we're
living way beyond our means we're
building up service obligations to the
holders of all that paper I mean when
you run a current account it's the same
thing as borrowing from the rest of the
world
the Chinese own well over a trillion
dollars of claims on the United States
and the Japanese and the OPEC producers
and on and on you could go so the idea
that we're getting something for free is
makes no sense to me and second you are
encouraging the mercantilist you know
export model of East Asia to become even
more virulent ly destructive that it
actually is because they somehow believe
they can export their way to permanent
prosperity and if they have to build up
massive dollar reserves greater and
greater and greater magnitude which is
exactly what they're doing
they seem to think that will work
obvious
in the long run it won't Japan is
already proof of that but it leads to
these kinds of massive imbalances and
distortions in the international trade
and monetary system that I believe are
on the verge of major conflagration as
the whole thing heats up let's talk a
little bit about your kind of political
philosophy and economic philosophy you
went to Michigan State you were a
congressman from Michigan before you
became budget director you've written
fondly of people like Hayek and Ed
Murray Rothbard Mises not so hot on
Friedman or certainly the Keynesian x'
where did these ideas come from when did
you get interested in economics and how
do you define yourself in in economics
well I think the thing you left out is
that yes I grew up in Michigan but I was
a anti-war radical as a student at
Michigan State so I guess in the heed of
you know the total nonsense of the
Vietnam War
I developed a skepticism of the warfare
state right and of the military and of a
adventurist
were you always a Republican no I was a
SDS quasi Marxist radical then as I went
to Capitol Hill as a staffer I began to
see the virtues of what I would call the
libertarian view which isn't that far
from in some ways they're the radical
left and we looked at it that I felt
what's the common thread well I think
the common thread is that you know
individual action and
freedom and liberty to pursue both
economic or other ends is the core of
what society should be built on and so I
became very interested in free-market
economics as a staffer on Capitol Hill
that I was elected to Congress pursued
that talk a little bit about who were
you a staffer for and then how you know
to say and then I was elected to
Congress as if you know you were walking
down the street and got hit by something
falling out of the window what what went
into those determinations well I was a
staffer for Congressman John Anderson
who was chairing the Republican caucus
considered a moderate but actually he
was the right kind of Republican in my
view because he was a social liberal and
an economic conservative and the work I
did was a lot of things on deregulating
transportation let's say the minimum
wage being counterproductive the need to
reorganize or eliminate the whole Great
Society set of programs that had
developed and so forth on the other hand
he as a moderate on social issues didn't
believe the government ought to be
intervening in our private lives and I
agree with that I agree with that then
and I still do now so it was out of that
period that I more fully form my
philosophy I ran for Congress then and
was elected in 1976 and had a chance to
begin to develop those ideas
legislatively maybe culminating in two
battles that I fought three really
before I went into the Reagan White
House one was deregulation natural gas
but that was the leading edge of the
whole fight with Cartwright statist
energy policy I was on the Energy
Committee and was one of the leaders of
the fight for deregulated natural gas
but opposing all the other Carter
nonsense like syn fuels cooperation and
regulatory standards for the energy
efficiency of toasters and so forth so I
began to see there the danger of
industrial policy or economic policy and
had some good experience fighting it and
it essentially or to that I mean Carter
was really very good at deregulating
because he also deregulated interstate
trucking railroads and airplanes but
then was just a statist in other in kind
of fanciful dreams that he had right
yeah well I think he depended on the
advisors he had some advisors who could
see the insanity of the CA B Civil
Aeronautics Board or the ICC trying to
set tens of thousands of rail tariffs
and so forth trucking tariffs but then
in the energy side because again of
short-run panic about what was going on
with OPEC and the oil price which really
was a function of inflationary monetary
policy but the bad monetary policy led
to a perception that there was something
wrong in the energy economy which
generated you know professor Schlesinger
and all his minions running around
trying to create a state-run energy
sector so I fought that and I learned a
lot about the danger then shortly after
that came the Chrysler bailout room and
I was from Michigan there were a lot of
Chrysler's suppliers in my district but
I strongly support opposed it gave a
loud speech on the floor about it found
that Lee Iacocca was about ready to run
me out of the state on a rail or wished
he could have brought but you know will
he have used a Chrysler but the thing is
I was right not only that but in the
next election I got the largest vote
ever so see what what does that say
about political economy though because I
mean there you are in Michigan and
you're running against one of the
fair-haired boys one of the major
employers in the state and saying like
no they should live or die in the market
and it didn't hurt you politically
because the rank-and-file of businessmen
in my district little machine tool shops
or someone running a plant where they
mixed fertilizers let's say and
distributed affirm what area were you
southwestern Michigan it was kind of
aggghhhhh half industrial knew that they
weren't too big to fail that if they
were ever up against the wall their
creditors would put them into chapter 11
and that's the way the system worked so
I had overwhelming support except for
the few squeaky wheels and couple
half-dozen suppliers who sold parts to
Chrysler and I think the problem we have
in our political system is that enough
politicians are not willing to think
that through they hear the squeaking
wheel and they respond and they really
don't have to I also was a liberal on
social issues voted against you know the
height amendment anti-abortion amendment
110 times and my district was very
conservative but they respected my
opinion so I think the idea that you
just have to couch out all the pressure
groups and all the squeaky wheels is not
really necessary but now thirty years
later is probably unavoidable because
money has become such a massive force in
the electoral process okay so you go
from being in Congress to becoming
Reagan's budget director and well you
know among other things what that
produced was your memoir the triumph of
politics but talk a little bit about
what you came into the Reagan
administration and you you believe the
hype right that he was going to cut
taxes and he was going to cut spending
it was going to cut the size and scope
of government of the federal government
and you went oh you know you worked long
and hard on coming up with the way to
cut taxes right great and that was
successful give for people who don't
remember really high marginal tax rates
in the US what did you cut what did
break and cut the top tax rates from all
right the top tax rate on earned income
was 50% of the time and I think we ended
up in the low 40s but it was about a 30
percent cut the the thing I learned out
of that tax cutting exercise was twofold
one is that and this is still not
focused on
there wasn't much popular support for
across-the-board rate reductions that
would benefit the average citizen or
even entrepreneur businessman the only
way that we got that through despite all
the urban legend that exists today was
through a massive Christmas tree of
special interest tax benefits and
loopholes that were appended to it the
numbers are simple the revenue reduction
was a trillion dollars over five years
from the tax cut half of it five hundred
billion was for the rate reduction the
other half was for oil depletion
incentives real estate tax breaks so in
other words you're giving back half of
that by well through three good yes and
so we ended up reducing the revenue far
beyond what was feasible even if there
had been a determination to really cut
spending but what happened subsequently
was almost no spending was cut right and
the defense budget soared out of control
we knew going in that there was a
commitment by President Reagan to
rebuild defense capability but what
happened in the early days was that the
Pentagon distorted campaign promises for
real growth of five percent which they
then raised a seven percent and Reagan
went along and then they started it from
a much higher base which is to say a
supplemental bill and as a result of
that defense spending got totally out of
control even as even though
discretionary non-defense discretionary
spending was was coming down a little
bit it did I doubt all that model we
caught very little out of the
entitlements other other than some
things that were appropriate and have
survived food stamp reform and AFDC but
the middle class entitlements weren't
cut there the whole complex of veterans
programs weren't cutting agricultural
subsidies were not seriously tampered
with and so as a result of that we may
have gotten a few tens of billions
annually of savings but
time most of that crept back you watch
listen I mean Reagan was famous for of
course saying that government wasn't a
solution to the problem government was
the problem why wasn't he more skeptical
of Pentagon claims of of what they
needed and of where where their
financial estimates were coming from
that's one of the yes may be mysteries
of the time and it's one of the factors
that led to the utter failure of
spending control he utterly was he was
utterly uninterested in any detail of
the defense budget of any of the claims
for dollars made by the Pentagon he gave
them a blank check without question and
that had a two-fold effect one it
ballooned spending just as we were
massively reducing the revenue but
second it created an enormous political
impasse and that is that we the spending
increases were so huge in defense that
it became almost impossible to get
anybody to look at you with a straight
face on Capitol Hill and say we're going
to go after the food stamp program or
we're going to go after Bennett you know
women's infants and children feeding
program or school lunches when you're
just showering tens of billions of
dollars on you know ammunition accounts
and spare parts replacements and a
massive expansion of the Navy which was
totally uncalled well here's a question
that said I mean at least we've won the
Cold War was was the defense build-up
was it necessary in your mind to you
know to us actually winning the Cold War
yeah I don't know someone said that the
the SDI the Star Wars was never a
program it was a speech right but the
speech was enough to make Gorbachev
realize that it was game over but my
view is that communism never worked the
Soviet Union was a house of cards from
day one in 1917
it was only a matter of time if we had
really believed our free enterprise
principles and our understanding of a
free society in capitalism we would have
realized in 1980 that the Soviet empire
was going to collapse sooner or later on
its own weight and we did need to try to
spend it in to collapse because it was
already happening so I don't buy the
idea that this huge Reagan buildup
defense build-up was what allowed us to
win the Cold War someone said that in
the 1980s we were at a race with the
Soviet Union to see who could reach
bankruptcy first they won by here but
it's not really the defense budget that
did it between 81 and 85 basically the
Reagan administration doubled the
national debt you left office or you
left the White House in 85 by 88 it had
gone up about two and a half times what
would you have done differently knowing
knowing how things played out if you
were starting again as budget director
in 1981 well I think you would really
have to sit down and make some very
large and honest conclusions and that is
how much defense do we really want let's
lay it out let's justify it let's
analyze the trade-offs and so forth
that's one big piece of the state then
what is the welfare state that we're
going to keep because we don't have the
political will to change it or we
believe it is necessary and if that's 24
percent of GDP or 20 percent of GDP then
what is the optimum tax system that will
raise 20 percent or 24 percent as the
case may be and therefore if we need to
lower income taxes which I believed at
the time and still do for incentive
purposes or because of Brackett cream
then what alternative revenue mechanism
such as a value-added tax or some other
consumption oriented tax do we need to
put in place to fund the government
we've well we have we had whether two
things come to my mind on that why don't
we have those
conversations about defense say where
you were saying earlier I mean one of
you know Obama won election partly as an
anti-war candidate and he is certainly I
mean he's disappointed I think everybody
maybe one of his daughters still
believes in him but you know clearly
he's a war president and he seems to be
relishing that role but you know have we
had an argument about what is the proper
role of defense defense spending has
gone up tremendously in the past ten
years you know why don't we have those
conversations well you know I think it's
partly the way the whole political
debate and ideology is evolved I'll
simply point out the last honest war
president we had was Truman mm-hmm
surprisingly and when the Vietnam or the
Korean war budget ballooned he demanded
the Congress Institute major tax
increases excise taxes income taxes to
pay for the war on a pay-as-you-go basis
now I'm not sure we ever accomplished
anything useful in the Korean War in the
light of history but he was right at the
time if you were going to do this we we
always should have had the principle
that if you're going to have a Vietnam
war or a Gulf War one or the Iraqi
invasion then attach it to war finance
to the taxes needed and one I think
you'll get a better decision people ask
do we want to spend a hundred billion
dollars on wars of occupation in places
that are the ends of the earth and not
strategically important if not because
of an explicit conversation but because
of historical realities since 1950
federal revenues have averaged about 18%
of GDP that seems to be the amount of
money at any point that we're willing to
shell out in a given year and it goes up
or down a little bit but it's never been
higher than about twenty point six
percent of GDP and it's at one of its
relative lows this year partly because
of the recession but you know why is it
impossible to say okay we're going to
peg our spending our total outlays at
any
year two 18% or 19% if we have that
conversation I mean are you is the
triumph of politics that we don't even
get to have those conversations where
that will have them but then we don't
really stick ourselves to it we don't
keep to a budget well first I think we
need to have the conversations but then
we need to recognize the underlying
demographic context of what the
steady-state claim on GDP is and the
whole entitlement structure retirement
entitled Social Security Medicare it's a
intergenerational Ponzi scheme the baby
boom is now inexorably moving towards
retirement and Beyond and so therefore
the share of GDP that it's consuming
continues to rise and if we take that
and add all of the other traditional
functions of government the slight
additions we've made to things like
education which are a bit out of control
and then a high level of defense
spending which we have but don't really
need in my view in this world you're in
the 22 to 25 percent range and I don't
see any way of getting out of that isn't
there I can say you're at the you're at
the leading edge of the baby boom right
right yeah I'm at the back end and I can
tell you that I nothing would please me
more than to see you and all of your
cohort go off at an iceberg somewhere
you know part of this and it goes back
to your experience in the Reagan White
House Reagan was very much a child of
the Great Depression and of World War
two and of an era in America of real
privation by the time you came along and
by the time I came along we were in the
in the baby boom it's a radically
different world I mean you you were not
growing old in your parents world in
your parents America you know you're not
talking about even in the mid 60s where
seniors had a much higher than average
poverty right now they're far below the
average poverty rate isn't it time that
we've restrike this intergenerational
entitlement I mean because that is the
problem in Medicare Social Security not
even so much Medicaid I mean it's time
to isn't it time to have that
conversation and say the the social
bargain that governed America from about
1935 until about 1995 no longer applies
yeah I think that conversation will
happen but only isn't that what the tea
I mean is that to talk about I mean
reasons for hope or thin reads for hope
is that what the tea party is about well
maybe there's a tiny glimpse that the
conversation is starting I don't think
the tea party is really that coherent it
is simply I think more reaction to the
economic turmoil that's occurred in the
fear that's been generated Main Street
and the and the appropriate antipathy
that's developed towards the crony
capitalists policy of bailing out
anybody who's big and strong like GM in
Goldman Sachs and so forth but beyond
that I don't think the conversation has
really started although the facts are
that the current generation of workers
are going to be turned into tax slaves
just like the workers in Ireland today
are finding out that they are and that
will have to change but it'll only
change when the crisis comes it's going
to be a very bad hair day but it sounded
do you I mean do you see anybody in the
political arena who is you know who
gives you hope or who seems to get what
you're talking about on that I think the
heart of the problem is our monetary
system is out of control our money
printing is destroying and distorting
and contorting our economy it's leading
everything to a kind of casinos
speculative system not a sustainable
productivity based growth system there's
only one guy who understands it it's Ron
Paul right well there's no one else what
he's newly ascended in terms of power
right that's true I mean so do you think
that that will be the beginning or could
that be the beginning well I think maybe
it'll begin to disinfect the process
maybe it will begin to shed some light
on all the pretensions and the
scholastic arrogance of the Fed feds
economists and the Federal Reserve it's
self and that maybe is at least a small
step towards beginning to address the
real problems in this country
well David Stockman thank you very much
for a really interesting conversation
thank you
[Music]